a new historical Total War is an
exciting prospect for the franchise as a
Warhammer fan I've been well catered For
with Total War Warhammer one two and
three but for those virtual generals
Among Us who prefer history books over
the game's workshops black Library the
pickings have been much more slim and
mostly in the form of Total Wars sagas
after a demo of some of the new elements
coming to the campaign as well as a few
hours Hands-On with some battles it
feels as though with Total War Pharaoh
creative assembly Sophia is firing on
all cylinders with the feature
experimentation and development that we
have come to expect with new historical
titles while also aiming to deliver a
much deeper fleshed out Total War
experience
thank you
I felt as though the setting of the 1200
BCE New Kingdom Period of ancient Egypt
in the late Bronze Age was an
interesting one as broadly speaking
Total War is double dipping into this
period of history with 2020's Total War
Saga Troy taking place in the same
Century while some of that Troy DNA is
visible and the time period feels a
little like treading familiar ground
total warfaro is a different Beast
entirely Pharaoh aims to showcase the
most extensive Empire in Egyptian
history mixing the beauty of the setting
with the brutality of the Bronze Age but
this combination poised to deliver new
gameplay and mechanics while also
exploring this period in depths
previously unseen in the franchise from
a campaign perspective the issue a hand
for the armchair Pharaoh will be the
late Bronze Age collapse a historically
devastating period of time that was
culturally disruptive violent and led to
the economic downfall of many regions if
this event the U.S ruler will eventually
need to delay battle against or weather
the storm to see what awaits you on the
other side
the pantheon of Egyptian gods is of
course a key element of ancient Egypt
that goes hand in hand with its history
I was curious if there would be any of
the history behind the myth that we saw
in Troy but during an interview with
game director title nikolov he made it
clear that while the gods are an element
in the game that can affect gameplay
Total War Pharaoh is a much more
grounded authentic game than Troy so we
won't be seeing any mythical beasts on
the battlefield from what I saw it feels
as though authenticity and immersion are
key to creative assembly Sophia's vision
of pharaoh and while some Liberties have
been taken with historical accuracy
either due to gameplay considerations or
simply missing historical records those
considerations and Liberties are being
balanced in a way that can also broaden
play a choice but it's not just Egyptian
rulers that make up the roster of Bronze
Age Leaders with eight leaders hailing
from three different cultures the
Egyptians Canaanites or Hittites or with
their own unique traits units identities
and varied faction leaders while
Egyptians May favor lightly armored
units utilizing chariots and archers
with hit-and-run tactics the Hittites
are experts in Metallurgy and Canfield
slow up but more robust armored units
while the Canaanites are a uniquely
flexible combination of Hittites and
Egyptian cultures favoring stealth
tactics and adaptable troops unit choice
and variety was surprisingly in-depth
and while the battles I played were
pre-made I was left feeling the Army
composition is an even more impactful
consideration than it was in previous
games with many of the new gameplay
elements that Pharaoh introduces making
your choice of an army all that more
impactful first among these is the new
Dynamic weather system battles can take
place across three main geographical
areas all of which can dictate the
terrain and potentially the changing
weather considerations in battle
skirmishes and deserts may fall victim
to Violent sandstorms that chips slowly
away at unit Health while adding extreme
penalties to your Arch's range and
accuracy thunderstorms may result in the
landscape becoming muddy and slowing
your units with the clap of Thunder seen
as an omen from the gods and reducing
morale as well as extreme heat that will
sap units of their stamina prevent
fatigue recovery and dry out the
surrounding Flora increasing the risk of
fire spreading throughout the battle as
Embers are carried on the Wind as the
weather system is dynamic the
considerations of a map's terrain and
your units are more vital than ever
warming sunny weather can dry up a muddy
creek opening up a potential flank piece
of High Ground can be made useless with
a blinding Sandstorm or if rain is
forecast you can use lightly armored
units to your advantage and further sap
the speed and energy from slower armored
foes as you force them to Wade through a
bog with the troops often reacting
accordingly to their changing
environment
that vision
all of the battles that I play during my
Hands-On use this weather system in one
way or another with one sticking in my
memory as especially satisfying I was
defending my capital city of menifa
that's modern day Memphis not the one in
Tennessee from a Siege during sweltering
heat while all the units were being
sapped of energy as the sun beat down on
them the fact that my Army wasn't having
to push battering rams or Siege Towers
increased my advantage but not only that
they were having to push said engines
through patches of dry grass an element
I was able to take advantage of with my
archers loosing fire arrows later in the
battle I retreated further into the city
to make use of the bottlenecks of the
streets my enemy used parks and open
areas still filled with trees and bushes
in order to Chase my troops but that
Greenery was also similarly engulfed in
flame taking the inhabitants with it or
simply cutting off an Avenue of movement
to the enemy it was only when I saw the
fires had spread to my own buildings
that I realized I wasn't quite the
Master General that I thought while
units have familiar abilities such as
shielded Fighters forming a wall they
also have new stances that go hand in
hand with util realizing the maps
terrain as well as their size and weight
troops can now advance and slowly push a
line forward hold position and maintain
their formation as well as the ground
they are on or use the give ground
stance to allow your units to slowly
backstep away while still facing the
enemy and remaining in combat so they
may slowly fall back without suffering
the additional damage that always came
with manually moving your units and
being shot stabbed or slashed in the
back your leaders units and their
bodyguards have always been some of the
most powerful and pivotal units in Total
War Games Pharaoh is building on this
element allowing for more unit
flexibility these bodyguard units will
follow their leader both into battle but
will also mirror their discipline
equipping your Pharaoh with a bow and a
chariot will change the unit as a whole
to one of Chariot archers or if you wish
your leader to take the front lines you
can equip them with a sword shield and
heavier armor and the troops that March
alongside them will follow suit talking
once more with game director toddler
nikolov he said that while there is some
evidence of pharaohs being trained in
multiple disciplines this was mostly
another element to further player choice
and flexibility ability while we've had
some control over our leaders and
Generals in previous games it has never
been to this depth which offers another
interesting layer of flexibility when it
comes to how players are able to prepare
for a battle if they want an extra unit
of arches For an upcoming Siege or a hit
and run Chariot unit if the approaching
enemy is the slow armored sword that
armor is also a more in-depth
consideration as it can now degrade as a
battle progresses and a unit takes
damage while I played a few battles
during the preview it took some time
before I could get my head around the
impact this had but it certainly meant I
had to be smarter with my armored units
while also meaning I was able to better
wear down the enemy using lower ranked
troops equipped with hammers and maces
it could potentially be a small change
but I think every veteran of Total War
can remember one time or another were a
particularly stubborn Squad of heavy
infantry became an immovable nuisance on
the battlefield something that will
hopefully be less prevalent here one
element in Army composition returning
General's May face is the lack of
Cavalry as in this time period there
were no traditional Cavalry units
instead chariots have been tweaked by
make them more diverse in their function
and utility than they were in previous
titles altogether both reworked elements
and new gameplay have really slowed the
pace of battles but so far I think it's
for the better a slower Pace means that
micromanagement is less important
especially when it comes to the precise
use of time skills and abilities I was
told that this was supposed to feel like
a classic Total War experience but also
being simpler more natural and
delivering battles that feel authentic I
was left wondering if this element could
be a dividing one within the community
or those who have come exclusively from
the Warhammer titles would respond but
for me so far I think this is how
historical titles should feel sound
tactical decisions feel more impactful
while a strategic slip up doesn't feel
so devastating reacting the dynamic
weather during battle and twisting it to
your advantage feels rewarding and the
idea of having to plan around the
elements themselves in the campaign
layer is both exciting and daunting but
it does mean that the game has more
Tools in its Arsenal to ensure that
skirmishes remain varied and engaging I
really do feel those elements of
Engagement and immersion too as the game
creates more opportunities for you to
tap into your strategic thinking with
more elements like troop type weather
armor and fatigue to consider and the
game looking gorgeous certainly helps in
that immersion Factor the Landscapes of
the battle maps look incredible with
sand dunes looking appropriately arid
Riverbanks offering Pleasant Strokes of
green against the desert or rocky Crags
or reacting to the ever-changing lights
and colors that come with the game's
weather system all of this space is host
to some of the most detailed units to
have featured in a historical Total War
title and since all the troops not just
your Heroes have matched combat
animations where individuals can be
blade to blade or deliver a killing blow
it was hard at times to take my eyes off
of the landscape and combat and instead
focus on winning the battle there's much
more of the game to see with my hands on
being confined to a few battles rather
than any turn to the campaign but from
everything I've seen so far my
excitement for a new historical Total
War has only been accelerated by my time
with the Pharaohs if you enjoyed this
preview be sure to share your thoughts
in the comment section below and of
course be sure to subscribe for Gamespot
so you don't miss any future coverage of
Total War pharaohs